this is so funny you probably know by
now that Donald Trump really likes
propagandistic grandiose news coverage
of his administration and of himself he
gets this twice a day
propaganda file of positive coverage of
him and pictures making him look strong
and manly that have appeared in mostly
right-wing media the best the smartest
the most effective president all of that
stuff he just loves so the other day
Donald Trump tweeted about an article
that listed 205 Donald Trump
accomplishments or so-called
accomplishments Donald Trump saying on
Twitter Washington Examiner Magga list
205 historic results helped Trump make
case for 20/20 re-election true he also
posted about this same Washington
Examiner article again on Twitter today
the article in The Washington Examiner
contains a list of accomplishments
written by Trump's own staff the
Washington Examiner writer who published
the article is named Paul Bedard but the
list of accomplishments is not a list
that Paul Bedard came up with it
includes such vague and amorphous
accomplishments as quote Americans are
seeing more money in their pockets
thanks to the booming economy and
President Trump is delivering on his
promise to bring back American
manufacturing that's not really an
accomplishment it's a campaign talking
point here's another one of the supposed
at 205 accomplishments in 2017 the Trump
administration eliminated 22 regulations
for every new one completely meaningless
out of context except when you look at
the article more closely you realize and
they say quote the following list is
compiled by the White House the list of
accomplishments that Donald Trump is
bragging about getting coverage for on
Twitter is a list that his own staff
wrote up and claim as accomplishments
this is government propaganda given to a
media outlet which is then reprinted
without any critical analysis of the
claims that it actually contains and the
saddest part of all of this is that his
followers start to repeat and parrot
this stuff as if these are actual
factual measurable accomplishments and
once you get rid of the things on the
list that aren't actually measurable
accomplishments and you get rid of the
things on the list that he's taking
credit for that actually it was Obama
who did and then you get rid of the
things on the list that are straight-up
lies there's nothing left here there's
really nothing left but unfortunately
that doesn't stop his low information
followers from continuing to tout this
stuff as major wins but the bigger issue
for me Pat is that there are media
outlets willing to print this stuff
there is no journalistic purpose served
for a media outlet to publish the list
of verbatim without critical critical
analysis without looking at each claim
and saying is this real or is this not
real is this measurable or is this
nothing
they are mirroring and amplifying
government propaganda and I don't care
whether it's a list provided by a
Democratic White House or a Republican
White House you should really only
publish this stuff if you're actually
going to critically analyze it this is
the tactic that Alex Jones uses right
like when he wants to break a story
about chemicals in the water turning the
frogs gay he'll go on and on ranting
about it and then he'll like have a
piece of paper in his hand that's
supposed to be like the source for his
commentary and then you see the camera
zoom in on the paper and it's just an
info Wars article like that's not the
most credible source of information
that's coming from you and your own
business that's exactly right that's
like me doing a story saying there is
breaking news posted by a staff writer
at david pakman.com that trump is orange
because of the amount of carrots that he
eats or whatever i am it doesn't even
matter I'll let have it that would be
far more healthy I think than the fake
tanning and I'm basically quoting myself
right I'm the source I've just written
an article and then I read the article
on my TV show what exactly am i doing so
this is absolutely laughable and
amazingly the guy has no shame because
he posted this initially yesterday or
the day
before he was called out about it a
thousands of times and then once again
he linked to the exact same list today
so you've got a you know if you like
this defend the purpose of posting it by
the Washington Examiner with no critical
critical analysis because all it is
actually doing is furthering government
generated propaganda